what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel and we got cool
auntie in the house
also guys like the video subscribe to
the channel sign up for our memberships
because it helps keep the lights on and
i want to move into a really cool place
in october so i can film some like do a
whole content house but we need to be up
on membership so we make sure we have
like a sustainable income next year
today i'm gonna show you the pure
delusion that i have dealt with in the
past couple of months right so this is
when i first started i was doing like a
call-in day on instagram that sort of
sort of space
back he's he's immediately like i'm
gonna let's celebrate like i want to
take you out and i'm like oh
how many how many dates have you guys
gone on one
okay yeah we went on one right before i
left that was our first first date
it's a date
go ahead sorry so now we'll go i guess
on the second one
but he's kind of short he's only like
five nine
oh that's you're you're what like five
i'm five eight that's tall enough right
not really you know manifesting a tall
man one of the other guys i'm talking to
is six foot seven
oh wow
and we'll be going out soon it's just a
matter of like scheduling we just
haven't been able to like link on the
schedules we both work a lot
mm-hmm
there's another guy who i just made this
whole take a tick tock about who
was like all about me asking me out
calling me all these pet names my love
and all this [ __ ] and then we're talking
and i was like oh you have the vaccine
right and he was like no
i was like you're not vaccinated and you
want to go out with me i'm like i'm not
going out with you you're not vaccinated
what are you [ __ ] me kissing you
you're not vaccinated i'm like
really oh i wouldn't care i don't care
in too many arenas where you have to be
vaccinated like i work at a yoga studio
where we're requiring proof of
vaccination that's where i am right now
holding always laundry i hope all these
music festivals where they're requiring
proof of vaccination and to me it's so
much deeper than just like do you or
don't you it's about that like i don't
want to have that debate with you right
like clearly if we don't view it the
same way we're not in alignment
right
so would you not would you not date
someone that was different than you like
politically no i wouldn't what are what
are your standards like what are your
requirements for a guy
i mean politically i definitely want us
to have the same view you know i'm a
black woman right so i'm not going to
date a white republican that would just
be a headache like why would we do that
to ourselves
okay
friends we wouldn't travel in the same
circles and we don't view this the world
the same
way to use the world the same as me and
even if you're not black but you're
white and you like get and understand
the black struggle fine that's fine
um but yeah i definitely want them to
have the same political views as me
because it's just
why bother and having those arguments
okay i'm just gonna turn into a fight
later
yeah no so what like what else
um
well they have to have a car this other
guy who didn't have a vaccine he didn't
have a car i was like how are you coming
to take me out you don't have a car you
know i'm not driving anywhere yeah
so that's like minimum requirement you
have to have a car um i've also realized
that i want someone that has like some
sort of creative or like
job and entertainment like i have um
you have to be very ambitious because i
am very ambitious i want to be able like
you know we'll spend our days or
whatever separately and then at the end
of the night i want to be able to come
together and talk about
he's got a vaccine he's got this he's
got do you know what right when i i
remember when i was younger and i
thought what do i want in the man
because women have this list i want the
man that had a paycheck
don't get the job i want the paycheck
because too many men at the time in my
day right they're hustling you never
knew where they were getting their money
from
i want the man with the paycheck a man
who loves children and the man who
respects his mom and the man that knows
about computers that could hold his
driveway
no telling like it wasn't i wanted a man
that could type because i think men that
can type are so sexy i know it sounds
really weird but you see a man eyeing
properly not the you see a man who could
type properly it is sexy i find it sexy
anyway and that's that's how i feel
about tools
yeah i can't fix anything and that's
that's all i wanted yeah you know once
you've got a ways a way slip you you
love children and you love your mom and
you know you could i found pink jobs and
blue jobs and you can do the blue jobs
but she still might she you know they
have to have a car you know i don't have
a car
why doesn't she have a car yeah i don't
know it's kind of i always think that if
you're an independent circle independent
woman no matter what color you should
have a driving license at least yeah
and she hasn't got a car but she wants a
man with this and he has to have a car
my man hasn't got a car he gave me his
car but you see people assuming oh he
hasn't got a car
he's got no reason to go because what's
the point of getting the car to drive
all that way around to work
when the trainer takes you there
but she wants a man with a car oh just
just wait just wait it gets better all
the exciting things that happened in
each of our lives right like okay this
other guy was like well i'm not rich i'm
a regular guy and i was like that's fine
but like i'm not a regular girl like
i'm i'm not so like
if you are going to date me like either
you have to be able to handle that or
you yourself also has to not be like
regular like i don't think like just an
average person like that to be boring
okay so
is there like a do you care okay would
you be cool with a guy that makes less
money but he's very he's a hard worker
like he's ambitious
yeah
okay so like if he was making like
let's say he just started his own
business but he makes 45 000 a year
would you date him
you wouldn't be able to afford my
engagement ring i'm getting an 8 carat
question cut vintage engagement ring if
you make 45 dollars a year it would take
what
four years no eight years
how much
i don't know anything about ranks how
much how much is that about two hundred
thousand dollars girl you want a two
hundred thousand dollar are you insane
yeah my ring has to sparkle from across
the street like you have to see that
[ __ ] it's good blind people that's so
superficial that's like so superficial
but it's about so much more than that
it's about the fact that you can afford
that right i go to yoga with this girl
who's an eight-carat diamond engagement
ring yeah the weed company and drives an
audi
so it's about more than just a it's
about the fact that you can afford that
but you you're you ain't her
you ate her
because i'm worth it she's going to end
up cuba is it cubic zirconia that's what
she's got it's a fake one that's what
she's going to end up with and this is
this is this is the thing is that these
are supposed to be business-minded women
i remember when i was talking to my man
about marriage you know how much my
ideal wedding costs it costs 1500 pound
including the ring and the honeymoon
1500
that is it
too many people start relationships in
debt she hasn't got a car but she wants
a 200k that's ridiculous
so you're gonna have a you're gonna have
a two 200k ring and eat what chips
mashed potato
well yeah i get into here here just wait
okay well i'm just thinking like
you're going to miss out on a lot of
guys because i'm telling you
but not not in a good way not in a good
way i'm telling you like my dad would
but if my mom asked for that from my dad
my dad would have told her to go find a
new boyfriend because there was no way
in hell he was going to spend 200 000
dollars on an engagement ring and that's
no and that's a multi-millionaire in the
top half a percent who had 10 kids my
mom never
he
he said he's built to the becoming that
he wasn't that originally right
he wasn't well he was making like six
figures in his early 20s oh nice so so
any any women woman with half a brain
would think this is a good this is a
good but my dad's like he's good with
money he's not like do you hear she like
yeah nice yeah i don't know i see it
because like do you hear how she's
trying to diminish like like she's like
oh well he built himself to be there
like what what have you done
he's there that's what you want he's
he's there that's the whole point is
that he's done it and it's like i grew
up with the men that you so called one a
date like all of my brothers make six
figures that are older than me so it's
like
she doesn't listen at all she feels like
she knows it all i always say would you
prefer a poor man with ambition or a
rich man with none oh a poor man with
ambition she wants the beach family poor
man with ambition because she didn't get
it she would want to reach me
i've dated the opposite and it is not
yeah it was fair like to me that's like
such an unwise investment to spend 200k
diamonds appreciate
oh my god no no
oh my god no
that's like i would rather put that in a
college fund for our kids or like yeah
they'll have that too
but this just sounds like not like real
to me you know really yeah like i don't
know for me like i told you like my my
status is going up like i just did a
music festival where i made 30 grand
over the years in one weekend you know
like i need somebody who can be on that
level right but the problem is like guys
don't care about your money
right there
i i know but it doesn't like
you know like
i'm just i think you're going to miss
out on a lot of guys with like this cr
like to me these are like crazy high
standards so
today i listened to my dating coach
she said you do not get your expectation
you get your minimum standard
see i wish
i have more experience these days
these type of these type of women were
new to me at the time because i wasn't
used to like the girls i grew up around
really weren't this crazy like i grew up
with athletes i've never seen anything
like that before yeah and so i like
i wish i could talk to her now because
now that i've dealt with crazy yeah i
know how to like talk to them in a more
direct way but at the time i'm like what
are you doing you like to see i know
like where are you now you know i
thought i could oh i could tell you look
at i'll show you she's still doing the
same [ __ ]
because you can do tick tock taylor the
sparkle
so she's still single yeah of course she
is she's always going to be single she's
got bad that's teachers yeah because she
acts like like this is when a lot of a
lot of girls come in
older
and
they raise their standards higher
even though the products like like they
don't put them that's like kevin samuels
used to say after 30 you put yourself on
sale
like even because it's one thing to come
at a guy with like a humble a humble
attitude
you know what i'm saying like a lot of
guys will date a girl with a kid but
like the problem is the girls that have
kids will act like they're better than
the men yeah like they don't humble
themselves and it's even with her like
you've never had a boyfriend you're in
your 30s like that's crazy yes she's
never had a boyfriend no never and she
wants that ring
and she thinks that she's gonna get a
man and she's never had a boyfriend but
the thing is is that now that's even
worse
because nowadays you've got all the tick
tocks and the instagrams who the hell's
gonna want that no but if he was a man
and he was looking at her page
oh no look at this look at this this is
one of the least self-aware things and
having the waiter filming and then and
then she's like she wants a six figure
man and he and he like politely was like
oh you're gonna film this too like you
realize he was i think he's been telling
a tongue-in-cheek and she just like oh
thank you
and then she's like oh i'm an influencer
that's like right over here you have a
hundred thousand followers on tick tock
you get 200 views and you're like i
i
don't even call myself an influencer
and it's just i think people just look
at her to laugh because
like and she's not a bad looking girl if
she didn't do that she's not great no
her attitude makes her like i'd say
she's fine but like
like i don't think she's like hot i just
think she's average but like her
attitude a lot of the prettiest girls i
know are the ugliest inside they're
really ugly
and and
no look at her enough flared nose no
why would you who has a dating coach
what 35 years old and you've got a
dating coach
i mean at 35 don't you know how to date
or doesn't the dating coach tell you
don't take out your phone no you see
this is the problem like this is a
rental fact so or basically like a
hundred percent of women want twenty
percent of men yeah so girls have been
going through their their twenties and
their even their early thirties like
they're side chicks yeah and so they've
never really had any relationship
experience so they don't know how to
like vet men properly
and so it's like they get to 35 and
they're still like mentally a teenager
because they've never had a real
relationship and so it's like yeah so
that's like what you see is she's
mentally still a teenager
there's a lot of that yeah there's a lot
and elder and that's why like you can't
have a conversation about like hey it's
not about happiness like that's an adult
conversation but like it's like you're
talking to teenagers but you know what
sooner or later it's going to balance
itself out
the mental women ratio because the men
are going to realize that half of your
women are stupid we don't want you and
it's going to even itself up
and then you're going to end up
lonely and barren with your dogs no
that's what happens yeah like
i don't i don't see like i don't see
her getting like saved unless like she
changes her behavior but like i just
don't see it happening because she lived
like here i'll keep up like even me
she's very dominarian yeah even here
i'll keep who is your dating coach
married yes and she has a baby and her
wedding ring is at least five carats
yeah
and her man is rich excuse me okay you
know he herself makes like 30 to 50
grand a month
coaching women in love
i mean good luck if that like works for
you i just like to me that sounds like
a 200k engagement ring like i think like
guys are going to hear that and be like
no
no no i have to have the man who's okay
with me maintaining you
right with maintaining you right like
you can be high maintenance but if you
are dating a man that is okay with
maintaining you you're fine you're not
high maintenance then you're just on
their level
okay but i'm just thinking like
like
i i know but those guys that are making
like
like that amount of money like
like i think they typically
want like the young like 21 22 year olds
i don't think so
maybe
what
i'm 30. so i'm not that old i'm actually
no i don't age to be wiped up by
somebody who's like in their 40s and
like ready to be serious and start
popping out babies a 21 year old unless
you're kylie jenner is realistically too
young to be like popping out kids
like you're too young
yeah i mean that's just i'm sorry the
200 dollar like that's crazy to me i was
a lot nicer than these people have tried
but she's just demonic like there's
something living in her she's scary look
at her she looks possessed
she's not right no seriously she's like
yeah yeah she's not no no no she's just
and you know that reminds me of she
right there when she was talking
she reminded me of my niece
and my niece is about oh seven eight
months i'm gonna get me this my dad's
gonna get me that this is what that's
what she sounded like an impotent child
they're they're mentally like like kids
well my friend's got a ring like that so
i want to get a ring like that and if
she can get one then i can
and that's what she's going on she
showed me what her like friend looked
like
her friend was hot like i'm sorry you
get hot girl privilege
like i i just think a lot of times girls
that are like fives
take advice from girls that are eights
but the eights can get away with [ __ ]
the fives can't
you said that
she's single yeah she's never in a day
is she a virgin
she's an undercover [ __ ]
that's what mommy is calling oh probably
she's she's an undercover yeah
because all she's doing is scoring
herself out to the highest bidder yeah i
mean what else has she been doing for
the last decade
like you've had 10 years plus
working her way up to sleep in the way
up to the top but she's never gonna get
there
but that's that's the thing is like
she's like a five she's probably
sleeping with eight but that's that's
what i'm saying the modern woman is a
side chick
they're just gonna look at her for a bit
of fun
yeah that's what i'm saying the modern
world because she thinks that she's eye
candy she's not eye candy no no
i can't get 30.
no sir you can be eye candy at 30 if
you're dating a 60 year old yeah you're
eye candy because i've dated an older
guy and everybody else i wasn't feeling
good about myself at that time he was a
fantastic man and somebody goes to me
jennifer why are you going to have such
an older man
i said because i'm always going to look
better than a woman his age
which is true it made me feel good for a
while you know and that's what it was is
that i was feeling bad about myself and
like compared to a woman so i'm gonna
i'm always gonna look good
but
it was just childish i don't even think
she'll date that old either
that's like
oh my gosh i cannot believe that's crazy
being someone that can make that amount
of money in a shorter period of time
like somebody who would say a musical
artist right a musical producer somebody
who's in entertainment somebody who's on
a tv show somebody who does like
concerts and tours that amount of money
isn't
the same
to them you know what i mean
what do you mean
like say i was dating somebody like a g
eazy right okay he makes 150 000 minimum
per show minimal that's what he makes in
a show yeah so if he does a couple shows
the 200 grand to him he won't even feel
it now let me let me show you g-eazy's
ex-girlfriend let me just because she
she said g-eazy hates luke for this
of men
this is who she's talking about if she
was to date a g-eazy that's his
ex-girlfriend
i know that like the raw i know like the
the like that's not a good look like the
way she dresses but like she's stunning
like that is a stunning girl and you you
think you're he's not even old he's is
he a star yeah he's a star that's what
i'm saying i'm saying like he's not even
huh i wouldn't even she the girls huh
yeah yeah but i'm saying that guy can
get girls like that you're not going to
have the same results why would you want
her this is something coming from
someone like i've been in a relationship
with a guy that was worth over a million
like i but i would never know she didn't
spend 200k on a rank
like to me that's like that's almost
like entitled like i'm not entitled to
his money
i mean
here's the thing
i can afford it myself
i will i would want you to be able to
get it for me right yeah get it myself
wow oh my gosh that's just
yeah i guess like we kind of probably
have different like
spending habits because to me i'm like i
would even if i had the money i would
never spend that on a ring
like this is she's serious she is dead
serious
but i'm also not that much of a jewelry
person right so it's like you're not
going to need to be buying me diamonds
for every anniversary or
jewelry all the time like get me my ring
and that's it i don't really need much
else
hi oh gosh
sorry
oh hi nikki i just added you to it
who is that purposely not putting your
camera around get me
i mean if you spend 200 calories
i hope i hope he gets you nothing ever
again 200k
i got the [ __ ] you don't you know i
don't if you want something buy yourself
love if you can't buy yourself why are
you gonna expect somebody else to buy it
for you 200k ring
okay
no i have to like connect it to the
thing hold on
i've done like a youtube live with her
she's
oh well
we'll go in a minute
sorry
i can i can drop you if this is a bad
time i just thought i'd add you to the
chat no just real quickly because we got
dinner and lamb and all this other good
stuff
listen
this i love this life this is hilarious
this i love you with the girls asking
for 300k diamond rings and everything on
this one these guys are now saying that
women hit the wall at age 20. and you're
talking about the 200 000
they'll be like oh god
but you guys are both women they're both
women so you really don't know
like how would you know but like being
around is being just like a lot of these
men they seem like they're in la la land
themselves
and it's like the people that they're
talking about is like who are you
meeting so as
two people are coming with completely
different expectations and like when you
were saying earlier you have pointed out
the person that was in the yoga class
she had a 300 000 ring the person your
coach she has a three hundred thousand
dollar ring it wasn't like base the
reason the ring that i have i wanted it
because of the fact that growing up some
there's a certain type of thing in my
family that that's what it was but it
wasn't because any of my friends had
that ring i couldn't care less what they
had so no i don't want it because they
have it i know i can have it because
they have it do you understand what i'm
saying like i understand that oh
having a hundred thousand dollar to two
hundred thousand dollar eight carat
diamond engagement ring is within my
grasp because i've seen it in real life
i associate with people who have these
things they're in my circles of people
they're in my friend groups
and i know i can have it because i've
seen it not it's not that i want it
because they have it i want it and then
i've seen it i've seen validation of it
in my in front of my face i've seen
buckingham palace
i've seen back in the palace that means
i can go and live there because i've
seen it
well and she showed me this girl like
the the girl she's talking about was hot
she was stunning i'm like i'm sorry but
she obviously thinks that she's as hot
as a girl hotter now what's her because
she's gonna get more expensive for me
well i'm not saying that you you
shouldn't want it because i do know
people that they've dreamt about a
certain type of specific wedding since
they were children guys stop screwing
girls like this
i need to stop screwing girls like this
because it's gassed up the ego some of
y'all are part of the problem because
somebody's taking her out on dates yeah
somebody's filling a red with this
rubbish would you like to take a picture
of me you know let's have gold you know
gold sprinkled on your food and that's
what's making her happy but okay oh my
god i wonder she can cook i don't think
because she eats out a lot
oh she actually could cook a little bit
i i met her in person once she cooked
decent yeah like i was the time i was
there she made snacks she can cook i
will give her that but
the attitude is i think
but i on the other hand i couldn't kill
us
so there was i i definitely understand
that and especially when it does come
time for people to get married where
people like oh why would you spend this
money why i'm like i don't care that's
that person's prerogative that's what
they want that's what they want so if
you're saying you see that because of
the fact that you see it on the everyday
person that you communicate with so you
knowing that it's something that's
accessible so if that's that thought
process
okay but
i don't know
i'm just saying like i think you're
looking for like a one percent guy which
is very rare and i think you're gonna
like
like you're gonna overlook a lot of guys
that literally make that amount amount
of money would like have that money to
spend but choose not to because their
values are to save money
like that's what i'm saying like you
would overlook like my dad in this
situation who's like top half a percent
but your dad's also getting your mom to
pop out 10 kids i'm not trying to pop
out
because my dad wanted her
number too you're talking about height
so it i didn't even know i thought most
guys won't talk like over six foot
so then when the you know different
people were sharing oh well this is the
percent of these type of i didn't even
know that was the thing because i'm like
most guys i know pretty tall
now you're adding the height to two
hundred thousand dollar ring but
i don't know girl
i know when the universe knows
well at least your options are open
you're not just trying to just outside
of the hype you're open to dating you
know every not everyone i was just
talking to this guy who doesn't even
have a headboard he has a bed and one
pillow and i said where's your headboard
he goes oh i'm just a regular guy i said
oh
i didn't say i don't want to talk to you
anymore i said okay
okay so okay so did i misunderstand
you're okay with like not getting that
stuff
how'd you see now
what how does she know
i was living in a studio apartment how
does she know that he's got no headboard
do you know when she's just she if you
close your eyes and listen to her you'd
think it was a a primary school child i
mean you think she's 15. she sounds
weird she's mentally
like excited like i'm gonna get this and
i'm gonna go she's been watching too
many fairy tales
like i i just thought like i thought you
said you need the 200k like would you
marry that guy
oh well i mean this is also the same guy
that doesn't have the vaccine so i
wouldn't even go out with him but
um
no here's the thing like the way i see
it in my head is that like by the time i
get there we will be in the place
to afford
those things and you like also you guys
like i the the circles that i run in the
people that i know like i meet very
influential people who can afford those
things all the time my everyday life i
mean pearl you saw my apartment like you
saw where i live you know what i mean
like i lived in my free building where
you have to make at least a hundred
thousand dollars a year just to afford
to live in a place where i live
right but i'm saying like to a guy like
money is nothing like men do not care
about your money so if money is nothing
they can afford my 200 000 engagement
ring
no that's that's not what i mean i mean
like money money money gives you no
value
so like i'm not more attractive to a guy
because i make more money
like if anything like they don't prefer
it because they like would prefer
someone with more free time to hang out
with them and like
i'm gonna make a video about that i
think it's actually ba
you think that's bs
yes
i rece after seeing the whole thing you
know the podcast that you were on and
seeing that whole drum i'm sorry about
the thing but this is something else
now that a lot of guys are saying that
they want traditional women traditional
women traditional women and then they
don't value the money and other stuff
i've now come up with a theory that the
only reason why they want these
traditional women that do not have money
is so that they can have the ability to
leave these women at will and have them
destitute because especially now with
the whole texas band of the abortion
laws and stuff and seeing these guys are
just like cheering thank god we can have
you barefoot and pregnant back in the
kitchen and not working anymore
you're the craziest thing is
when the u.s planned parenthood is
literally a racist organization and it's
like you think that this is sex it's
like
they i i just like why is that that girl
is married to in the bottom corner i'm
like that's your opinion of men they
want to leave you high and dry
she's married yeah
not not the girl like the ones yeah i
was surprised at her coming
yeah she's married wow and even and even
so in plan i don't know if you know
about the like roots of planned
parenthood yeah and so it's like it's
like it's literally a racist
organization like so i don't know why
like because they're both black so i'm
like shouldn't you be for these bands
they just don't get it do they no they
just referred not to have any children
and let somebody else rule their life
and these people that want to be
independent can't be independent and be
running your own life with planned
parenthood in your life because you're
not independent then somebody else is
running your life for you or the
government like the government a lot of
women depend on the government with
their free programs and like they're not
saving women on two-thirds of the
consumer debt they're not saving for
retirement so don't spend money on
rubbish
and the thing is is that now they're
blaming these um by now pay data you
know there's this big thing about oh
it's causing women to go into that
nobody's making them a shop and buying
up here later
you know even during covert when
i was it's not really surprising me
primark tick tock
i didn't know that was a thing what tick
tock primark they're cheap clothes okay
and everybody the women are going out
there
and they're buying all this sheet for
all these sheet clothing to show on tick
tock but where are you going and you've
got all these cheap clothes
that not even oxfam would take anymore
because they're so cheap
and you're just going to keep on buying
and buying i've got i've got clothes
from when my son was yeah me too i have
my i have stuff from high school it's
like when i saw your mum stressed and i
thought wow
she bought classic dress that she could
wear now this year and actually the year
after but half of these things that they
as a disposable it's trendy and it goes
in and out and women just spend money
like what no that that's
the lady on the bottom right i was
surprised at her comment she sounded
like her head until she said that
yeah she
yeah she's she's got like i at first i
thought that that money thing didn't
really matter but i'm starting to
realize no these guys just want the
ability to leave you high and dry and
then laugh in your face
do you call it new thing that i'm just
like
what they really want i don't i don't
think so like because
i don't i don't think so i think like
like
like money just isn't like attractive to
them like they just don't like like when
we see an ambitious like driven man that
turns us on that does not turn a guy on
to like like i think they don't want
like a girl that's like bad with money i
think that's like a turn off i think
that like they don't want a girl that's
like
you know doesn't like his terrible
finances whatever but like i just don't
see guys like
being like oh my gosh that's so sexy
she's the ceo like the same way girls
are right like that's true
the men that date me are attracted to my
ambition
yeah because you're dating a guy with no
headboard
but she's not even she looks like a size
14 there yeah i bet she is she's chunky
yeah
she's scary she she's no she looks
demonic
look in her eyes like she looks
possessed like she's not right i think
rather than spend their money on the
dating coach she should be spending
money on the therapist yeah yeah she's
sure because she's got some serious
issues she's i don't know she's living
in fantasyland
i would have agreed with you paul until
watching that podcast that you were on
and all these women that they're pushing
these traditional values on that could
barely even formulate a
complete sentence and that's why i
wanted to do the reaction with you on
there because these other girls who are
normally on there but this is
entertainment
like it's entertainment
nobody sends them to come on the show no
people come in there and they talk
and they're like pushing the whole thing
that we don't care about this we don't
care about that meanwhile these are just
only fan girls that you're trying to
push these type of values on i'm like
this whole thing makes no sense
well well that's the problem with fresh
and fit is they just bring on like the
trashiest girl and i said that on the
podcast i was like do you guys think
you're in like a little bit of a bubble
like i was like but i think that doesn't
they see women as though i don't think
they see women as like
actual functional human beings and this
is so running my own podcast this was
before yes you are in a bubble and the
girls that come on are going to be
trashier because they make you more
money
but it's indicative of society as a
whole
so while maybe those girls are the
extremes i think there's a lot of
reasonable women out there but there's
still reasonable women that still have
sort of a modern mindset yes so it's
interesting like watching this bat
because i would probably change my
answer now slightly
okay
hello
hi
he was on earlier he said he wanted to
come back on
um
i
i totally disagree with the point of
um
what was it men
women
um
are thinking that men
uh want women that um earn like a lot of
money or more money than
that's just simply not true you're hard
you're kind of low so can you say that
again
it's like more
i said
i said um men don't men don't value
uh
women that make a lot of money that's
it's not really a turn on for us guys so
how much money do you make sir
you got it
oh gosh
hello how much money you're back
okay
maybe it's maybe it's my device let me
let me switch onto how rude that is
that is so rude it looks like she finds
them in maybe that's why they know that
she's easy i have never asked a guy how
much money he makes i have the only
reason i knew that x had that much money
was because he told me i never asked i
do not like i think that is so rude i
think the only reason why that's all
right i've only known how much
two one because i was a supervisor so i
knew how much she got paid and then
scott from scotland because we were
talking about it because we had the both
same positions
but because he was in scotland and i was
in london i earned more from the same
position so that's how come i knew
because we were studying together and we
had to it was one of those topics that
came up but i don't know how much my
mind earns it's not my business yeah
it's rude you don't know how much you
don't know how much i earn oh it doesn't
maybe that's the leading question hello
pleased to meet you how much do you earn
should i make the man run away
[Music]
no i think
men that make like 50 000 a year are
gonna be the ones that say oh we don't
care about how much money the woman
makes [ __ ]
you know it's for
it that's really really sad with all her
high classness so she's wearing around
her neck it's not a proper lady scarf
you know women wear scarves around there
now and and and knows you what she's
trying to do i don't know she dresses
trash yeah i've seen that's not classy
no nothing she's got on you've got all
the extra armpits can you see underneath
here all the boobies are spilling out
all the extra armpits and it's like what
what is your dating coach teaching you
not to dress properly
i think people talking about my theory
about um i don't believe that because i
just think that they want to be able to
be the bread runners to leave these
women destined to and begging because
after the whole thing um only fan thing
see i've learned so much better how to
handle these type of girls so i kind of
hate watching it back because i'm like i
would say so much more now than i did
that's what she did i was watching that
one that i was on i just thought why
didn't you say this i should have said
that
so many guys are so excited i can't wait
till these women fail in the nation
because now i would say why is that your
opinion on men why do you feel that
strong like like that says more about
you and it doesn't matter
what what what has what has men done
them men must have done them something
for them to hate them so much they've
got us have hang-ups yeah but like
that's someone's fault and then it's not
i would say nobody can treat you bad you
will have people thank you yeah yeah
it's like nobody can talk to me horrible
down the phone
because the power's in my hand the red
button that's accountability so
everybody's blaming everybody but oh no
you know they're just completely out and
homeless and begging for people to
change outside he's like
jesus lord you want you
calm down well no i think it's not that
i think like people don't enjoy like
seeing people cheat and when
so like in this example like these girls
are kind of cheating right they don't
really have any real skills they're just
like hot
sell their body on the internet and then
they get to drink
that hotness right
what these girls they have to maintain
that hotness you work out these girls no
easy like skinny and pretty but other
ones like they have to work out they
have to do like
you know a lot more than i have to do to
be able to take their clothes off on the
internet and have people want to look at
them
yeah but like maybe
could you find the motivation to like
take like
not eat as much like that's not 30k a
month not having to be in the gym so i
don't know
i said i could make that in a month not
having to be in a gym well i know but
we're not talking about you we're
talking about the only fans girls like
that's that's the topic like i think men
like are happy with their downfall
because you're watching these girls
cheat essentially and when because a guy
could never do that so when they say
like oh like they're in the streets
whatever like i mean usually like it's a
certain type of guy that's gonna like go
out of his way to comment that but i'm
saying like it's i would guess it's
because we're essentially watching them
cheat
and when like
i'm at work and i'm gonna have to do
some other work so i'll if you're still
on later we'll come back but okay okay
yeah
bye but that's also then if we're saying
that
okay that's the interaction
in the show what it's install no i think
that's her closet maybe i don't know
okay yeah i think oh she was going to
work she said yeah yeah all right
she sells glitter i don't know
why do i need so many clothes that look
like a shop i don't know either i i
don't like having a lot of clothes
because i can't manage at all you look
like a shop that's ridiculous
she wants 200k on the ring she's getting
extra money from the men that she's
dating she's i because she's a secret
[ __ ]
yeah i reckon she's a secret at all yeah
i don't know i just know i reckon it's
not what she does it's how she does it
and by the time she's finished sleeping
with all those men she's going to end up
50 having to buy her 200k ring herself
and end up with on her own she'll be
able to afford it she's not good with
money because i even was talking to her
like about how the average american
doesn't have 10k saved and at that point
like before i came here i had a really
like i had a year's salary saved so i
could do youtube because i wanted to try
it and so i was like let me save money
so i could like take the risk you know
and i was like i don't understand how
people get to be so old and they have no
money saved and then she's like oh i
don't i'm like what then why are you
living in this apartment like
and the thing is is that all that money
that she's got and she doesn't own the
apartment she's renting it i'd rather
just take the money and go and buy a
cheaper apartment
then rent an expensive apartment just
for the sake of showing
because that's all it and you see the
thing is it's like she's living the
internet life that's what it is i was
realized she's living the internet like
she's gone on they're all gone on the
internet cool the internet's dangerous
isn't it and we thought in my day it was
good for education but it's good for
education but it's done for educating
dumb women in their dumb brains
it's not reality no just because it's
got real people in it but then films
have real people in it they just happen
to be actors
do you know what i mean adverts have
real people in it
but they're looking at all this with the
clothes and the glitter and oh and
they're just getting carried away with
it and when they're out what they're
gonna do they're gonna be a section of
internet or is it only fans 50 plus or
something like that
oh my gosh
[Applause]
this is where we shouldn't be single but
no but there's no there's no man that's
going to want to no man is going to want
to they'll take her out on one and she's
not even eye candy maybe they're just
fortunate is feeding
yeah something like watching women eat
you know maybe that's what it is it's
like yeah maybe she just dates feeders i
don't know
well i don't know but no she's not fit
she's not attractive she's about
feminine no and no she's not even
masculine she's crazy
no she she's like she's delusional and
everything's like
yes you know like a child at christmas
oh my god no she hasn't come down on
that time she's 13.
like mentally it's it's that like
there's ha i see her all the time in
women she rhymes with these women like
it's online so it's gotta be true at
least this person's doing it online
somebody's like i can do it
you know whatever's happening online i
can do that and then the only reason why
she moves to that place is so that she
can have that internet live and the
internet closet and everything like that
but that's scary no i know
she's scared okay well
i enjoyed having you on the channel
today i enjoyed being here yeah we're
gonna have you back you're a fan
favorite you're like give her a show
give her a show
yeah
so we'll definitely have you back um you
have any final thoughts you want to tell
the people tell the delusional women
shut your mouth and shut your legs
yeah that's it shut your mouth shut your
legs and stop being close pegs listening
machine oh it's a clothespin you squeeze
the head and flex it
oh my god okay guys
subscribe to the channel like the video
and let me know in the comments what we
should have auntie react to next also
sign up for our memberships that helps
keep the lights on here at the studio we
will talk to you next time bye